teilen schafft gemeinsamkeit gastgeber
domenicali empfängt im zürcherischen
dübendorf seine gäste die private stube
wird zum halböffentlichen history das
menü rustikal und preiswert gerade mal
15 franken bezahlt jeder gast die
teilnehmer haben sich vorher online
angemeldet
hier geht es um kulinarik und kontakte
was ich bekomme es halt wirklich
soziales leben das einfach leute in
meiner wohnung kommen und vietnam mit
der hand haben
die online-plattform jury kocht
existiert seit letztem november 130
mitglieder sind bereits registriert
im ausland sind die do it yourself
gaststätten schon länger populär wales
gehört heute zu den wichtigsten sharing
plattformen überhaupt ganz den ums
finanzielle definiert die hanne bis wo
eigentlich nie kritisch und david tyler
ohne gegenwert würde ich sagen
die erfolgskurve der sharing economy
zeigt steil nach oben
für den zukunftsforscher stephan
siegrist ist die ökonomie des teilens
eine nachhaltige idee aber auch ein
etikettenschwindel
es war das sharing konzept was ich
momentan zurück setzten viele laien sich
wenn es mal präzise erlegt eigentlich
nicht sharing konzept sind sondern es
geht auch um renting umformierte wird
nicht einfach kostenlos zur verfügung
gestellt werden und das war in teilen
eigentlich so sondern sie sind uns einig
mit rhetorik verbunden wenn wir die
große reithalle geht vom vom autoteile
carsharing ergehen wie wohnen geteilt
werde es über taxis als wie das wii
spiel da wird letztendlich sitzt immer
über einen ökonomischer profit verteilt
in der share economy sind alle
konsumenten zugleich auch produzenten
sogenannte presse
wie also werden wir in zukunft leben
wir werden teilen statt besitzen
schreibt die renommierte soziologe
jeremy rifkin seine prognose im jahr
2050 wird es keine unternehmen mehr
geben sondern weltweit kooperieren der
gemeinschaften und verbände auch im
fürstentum liechtenstein wird geteilt
die mitglieder der zukunftswerkstatt
suchen neue wege abseits von
besitzdenken und konsum waren ideen
sammeln für ein nachhaltiges
wirtschaftssystem in der region die
sharing academy wird regelmäßig geprobt
und durchgespielt
die gemütlichen veranstaltungen sind
beliebt im ländle tauschen und teilen
statt kaufen angewandte
kapitalismuskritik sozusagen die
wachstums passiert gesellschaft einfach
zurück zu fahren und weniger wenig bio
anteil steigern dass ihre praktischen
ansatz dafür diese art des teilens
schafft eine neue verbundenheit kann
daraus eine gemeinschaftlich
organisierte gesellschaft entstehen
geben ist seliger als nehmen gilt im
ältesten sharing kompetenzzentrum der
welt in der kirche alois metz leitet die
pfarrei sankt johannes in luzern er weiß
genau warum wir verteilen wollen aber
dennoch im inneren widerstand scheitern
da kommt wahrscheinlich eine ganz große
angst des verlierens die streichen wir
die butter vom brot was ja völlig völlig
utopische stimmt nicht es ist irrational
par excellence da ist teilen wirklich
ein bilanzieren was auch wahrscheinlich
gelernt haben das ist bruder
ich gebe dir aber dafür erwarte ich
mindestens so viel von dir
der seelsorger plädiert für einteilen
dass empathie höher gewichtet als profit
in der art des des teilens könnten wir
das zum ausdruck bringen aber dann wird
verschenken sie verschenken
es gibt für mich ein wunderschönes
gedicht von konstantin wecker ich
schenke ich hier will alles und gar
nichts mehr
einfach ein tropfen im meer